my friends the future is now and we are
going to destroy it because thanks to
suggestions from MK and brandon Crilley
will be battle testing two of the most
cutting-edge VR systems out there Eric
if VR exists how do we know we're not in
a simulation right now trust me Justin
we're not not just taking the red goo
you
it's safe to say the age of virtual
reality is finally here and if we're
going to put these things in our heads
we better make sure they're built up
first up Samsung's gear VR which uses a
note 4 as a display and is even
available at Best Buy next our throwback
device Nintendo's Virtual Boy awful and
where it deserves to die finally the
oculus rift dk2 while it has a steep
learning curve it still represents the
best headset currently on the market and
this one well it's my roll so sorry
action
oh that was like such a crunchy sound
well let's go test statistic please work
please still work I see screens here let
me put it on yet this is the night of
the Roxbury oculus rift game where you
make the same motions oh it's really
jittery yeah it's not great the
accelerometer must be busted because
it's really much more jittery than it
was it's not really usable or and I feel
a little sick so I wouldn't want to use
this for an extended period of time
okay that's fail well that sucked
yeah it didn't sound good really it's
about how the phone is inside of here
this is like the old person in
sunglasses okay it's a little out of
focus there's some fake hair in there
but besides that it seems to still work
hey I think it's passed sturdy like a
break and made a sturdy sound yes like a
brick
let's go plug this thing in and see if
Mario can still play his red and black
game of tennis yeah okay so here we go
nineties technology weed it up the
batteries in the controller because sure
oh I think who works damn it
action
oh that's a Deadhead right so if the
damage of the impact didn't kill it may
be getting run over by the cartwheel I'm
more concerned about Steve he's to pay
good as new Steve fine yeah she's all
right this
I don't know worked if you come on down
and we'll test okay okay this seems fine
I mean there's a little scratch on the
lens No thank you shake plugging it in I
don't hear anything
Oh oh it just loaded okay this is past
this thing yeah still work let's just
take a moment to comment how stupid
people look when they use we are I look
stupid
no you look you look super cool yeah is
that the game I think Mario chance just
left the building I'm entering the
virtual world prepare for a tennis
experience unlike any other
uh-oh I was like why is this weird the
left screen is out haha so it's no
longer 3d it was like a saying and nor
was it ever virtual if you were like a
pirate this would work okay
while you're in the virtual world you're
practically blind in the real world so
we wondered what would happen to your
precious piece of tech if someone snuck
into your house and tried to hit you in
the face with a baseball bat let's find
out ready okay here we go don't miss
I'll try not to didn't you hear me say
don't miss it because you said don't
miss okay all right I've been replaced
with a new batter I'm terrible at
baseball I'll give it a shot
r / oculus please forgive me
yes that was what we wanted I did it oh
my and I feel sad inside I think it
still might work and I hit it pretty
directly slipping in and from the
virtual world still works ha ha visually
lens is not cracked everything is fine
but we've lost the touch Patrick okay so
it's dead but it definitely took a fair
amount of looking so impressive how
about a round of applause for the gear
vr do you think VR is another fad or the
next big thing let us know in the
comments below
justin is there something different
about you new shirt hell new new lab
coat you got it
new it I can tell I'm very perceptive
like a car wash